en este vídeo vamos a hacer un breve
argumento para probar que las diagonales
de un rombo son perpendiculares
recordemos que un rombo es un
paralelogramo en el cual los cuatro
lados miden lo mismo por ejemplo una
figura de este estilo está igual este
igual este igual a éste de hecho si un
cuadrilátero tiene sus cuatro lados
iguales entonces va a ser un
paralelogramo pero bueno ahorita no me
quiero meter en eso lo que sí es que
quiero hacer una aclaración resulta que
algunos rombos son cuadrados por ejemplo
si tenemos por aquí un cuadrado un
cuadrado entonces ahí tiene sus ángulos
de 90 eso no es lo que hace que sea un
rombo sino sus cuatro lados iguales vale
entonces este de aquí es un rombo los
cuadrados son rombos pero no todos los
rombos son cuadrados puede haber rombos
un poco más flacos como como algo de
este estilo con sus cuatro lados iguales
pero que definitivamente no son
cuadrados va
con esto en mente ahora sí vamos a
pensar en por qué las diagonales de un
rombo son perpendiculares para eso voy a
dibujar acá un rombo pues un poco más un
poco más derechito un poco más acomodado
o sea simplemente va a ser una figura
con sus cuatro con sus cuatro lados
iguales pero simplemente la rote vale
entonces éste lo rote no he cambiado las
propiedades del rombo sigue teniendo sus
cuatro lados iguales pero ahora está un
poco más bonito para trabajar
bueno aquí ya tenemos este rombo lo que
voy a hacer ahora es ya es dibujar una
diagonal horizontal vale una diagonal
horizontal va ahora observemos que ambos
triángulos tanto el de arriba como el de
abajo comparten esta diagonal que acabo
de dibujar esta de aquí
esta de aquí sale pero además también
comparten sus otros dos lados este lado
es igual a este que es igual a este que
es igual a este porque son los lados de
un rombo entonces estos dos triángulos
de aquí son triángulos iguales son
triángulos congruentes si recordamos
nuestras clases de geometría eso se
puede probar con el criterio lado lado
lado pero bueno entonces estos dos
triángulos son triángulos congruentes el
de arriba es congruente al de abajo y
bueno gracias a eso los ángulos también
son congruentes entre sí es decir este
ángulo que está aquí arriba digamos en
el vértice del triángulo isósceles es un
triángulo isósceles porque dos de sus
lados son iguales este ángulo de acá es
igual a este ángulo de acá y también
tenemos que los ángulos de la base son
iguales bueno o sea para empezar este de
aquí es congruente a este de acá porque
el triángulo de arriba es isósceles pero
además esos dos ángulos son congruentes
a los ángulos del triángulo de abajo de
estos ángulos que están en la base del
triángulo isósceles de abajo porque son
triángulos congruentes vale
bueno entonces ya tenemos todo esto lo
que vamos a hacer ahora es trazar una
altura del triángulo de aquí arriba
entonces déjame tomar el color verde
para trazar una altura entonces de aquí
arriba voy a bajar perpendicularmente
hacia la base entonces ahí tenemos una
altura del triángulo de arriba entonces
aquí tenemos que llegar
perpendicularmente bueno pues como aquí
tenemos un triángulo isósceles entonces
este triángulo es totalmente simétrico
con respecto a esta altura entonces este
segmento de aquí va a ser congruente a
este segmento de acá déjame ponerle tres
marquitas vale entonces la altura llega
al punto medio de la base de este
triángulo isósceles eso también se puede
probar formalmente utilizando algún
criterio por ejemplo como este ángulo es
igual a este ángulo y este es igual este
entonces los otros ángulos son iguales
como como ambos triángulos comparten
esta altura entonces tenemos que los dos
triángulos son congruentes y entonces
estos segmentos miden lo mismo pero
bueno esta es una forma complicada de
decir qué
una figura simétrica con respecto a la
altura y que por lo tanto estos dos
segmentos miden lo mismo bueno entonces
trazando una altura llegamos al punto
medio resulta que si trazamos la altura
del triángulo de abajo pues también
llegamos al punto medio por la misma
razón vale entonces tenemos tenemos que
aquí la altura llega perpendicularmente
al punto medio y por lo tanto podemos
pensar en la combinación de estas dos
alturas como la otra diagonal del rombo
entonces eso está padre verdad porque
ahora tenemos que la diagonal de bueno
que une estos dos puntos es
perpendicular a la otra diagonal a la
que une estos dos puntos y no sólo eso
sino que además de esta diagonal corta a
la otra en el punto medio y también
podríamos hacerlo hacia el otro lado es
decir ahora podríamos fijarnos en este
triángulo este triángulo isósceles de
aquí este triángulo isósceles y en ese
triángulo tenemos que bajar esta línea
rosa es una perpendicular y por lo tanto
llega al punto medio de hecho eso sucede
en cualquier triángulo en cualquier
triángulo isósceles si tenemos
ángulo isósceles a está un triángulo
isósceles digamos que el lado de abajo
es la base entonces este lado es igual a
este de acá y trazamos la altura y
trazamos la altura que aquí llega
perpendicularmente entonces tenemos que
esta altura parte la base en dos
segmentos de la misma longitud vale
bueno aplicando esta idea tanto en un
sentido como en el otro o sea digamos
ahora en este triángulo de acá tenemos
que esta altura llega al punto medio
está también y por lo tanto esta
diagonal también corta
perpendicularmente a esta diagonal en el
punto medio vale entonces tenemos esa
cosa bien interesante de los rombos si
trazamos sus dos diagonales entonces son
perpendiculares entre sí y además se
dice can es decir se cortan en sus
puntos medios